good morning it's tuesday it's been a
bit of a stressful week here so i'm
wondering if we can try some calm
repeated movements so i have a long-term
plan to draw 170
000 or so circles i like drawing circles
for a number of reasons for starters
because it is impossible the nature of
my shaky hand and the writing
instruments i use mean that i will never
quite draw an actual circle there will
always be something oblong
or edged or incomplete in every attempt
one of the main pleasures of doing
something over and over again
is realizing that even the smallest
actions cannot actually
be repeated because each circle is
non-circular in its own particular way
just as even though i've signed my name
half a million times
i've never quite done it the same way
twice in one of the episodes of my
podcast the anthropocene reviewed i
discussed the monumental circle drawings
of the japanese artist hiroyuki doi who
began drawing after the death of his
brother
because he found that the circles gave
him relief from the sadness and grief
i also find that repetitive actions
offer relief provided i choose them and
don't find them too physically or
mentally taxing
of course it's easy to chalk that up to
my having obsessive-compulsive disorder
but studies have found that most people
are more focused and retain more
information when they are doodling
than when they are not now to be clear i
understand that drawing circles
doesn't like accomplish anything i've
focused a lot of my life and energy
around
being productive but i've also taken a
very narrow view
of what constitutes productivity like
making youtube videos is productive
but spending time walking in the woods
with my kids
is not writing is productive but only if
i'm writing for an audience
email is productive but twitter isn't
when a good artist makes art
that's productive but when i make art
that's unproductive
but amid all that thinking around
productivity i rarely pause to consider
what i actually want to produce
books and videos and podcasts yes but i
also want to produce
joy i want to produce deep connections
with people i love i need to produce
gratitude and hope that can live
alongside the worry
and fear i also need to produce and i
want to produce some not
quite circles not least because they
expand my definition of productive
while also asking me to pay a particular
kind of attention
like i enjoy watching for example how
even little changes have big
impacts on the picture whether it's
switching between
pens or following a circle that branches
away from the others
but there is also something else i'm
trying to do which is to understand
what 170 000 actually
means humans in general have a
notoriously difficult time
distinguishing
among large numbers like a million
seconds
a billion seconds and a trillion seconds
all sound to me like i don't know very
large amounts of time
but in fact a million seconds is around
days a billion seconds is just under 32
years and a trillion seconds is 31
710 years put another way 10 million
seconds ago
my life was basically identical 10
billion seconds ago
louis xiv was king of france and 10
trillion seconds ago
nobody was king of france because our
species
probably didn't exist yet thinking about
big numbers that way
helps me some but still it's difficult
for me to contextualize large numbers
and so i suppose i am making these
circles because i am trying to figure
out how to count
to a hundred seventy thousand i'm trying
to understand
just how many that is this is circle 589
hank i'll see you on friday